hi everyone welcome to
the homeroom live stream sal here from
khan academy a happy
national constitution day for all of
y'all from the united states and we'll
be digging deep into the us constitution
with one of the world's
leading experts on it so start putting
your questions in
on facebook and youtube and we will be
able to surface these questions
but before we jump into our conversation
i'll give my standard announcement
reminder that khan academy
is a not-for-profit organization we can
only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so
please go to khan academy.org donate i
also want to give a special thanks to
several organizations
that stepped up when they realized that
we were running at a deficit even before
the covet
crisis hit and when covet hit we had to
accelerate a whole
series of our programs our server costs
went up because our traffic went up
dramatically
registrations went up so special thanks
to bank of america google.org att fastly
novartis
but i will remind everyone we are still
running at a deficit
especially for next year so any support
you could provide
is very very valuable so with that i'm
excited to introduce
jeff rosen who i've known for for many
years because we've collaborated
on some things at khan academy jeff
good to see you happy national was it
constitution day
happy constitution day sal absolutely
and it's great to see you too
so glad to be here so so maybe a couple
of quick questions
why is today national constitution day
september 17th
so september 17 1787 was the day the
constitution was signed in
independence hall in philadelphia it
wasn't made a national holiday
until 2004. uh there have been
precursors of it in 1940 there was
something called citizenship day but
basically ever since
a law in 2004 sponsored by senator
robert byrd
the u.s has recognized the anniversary
of the day when the constitution was
signed
makes a lot of sense and for those not
familiar what does the national
constitution center do which you lead
the national constitution center like
salt uh like your
phenomenal work saw is a non-profit that
teaches people about the constitution
and we have this amazing online resource
called the interactive constitution that
contains
videos so that we've done together with
you and with people like justice neil
gorsuch and elena kagan
it has early drafts of every provision
of the constitution
it has essays by leading liberal and
conservative scholars describing what
they agree and disagree about the
constitution
and most excitingly uh recently we're
offering live classes on the
constitution
that are you can find that on the
interactive constitution or at
constitutioncenter.org
three days a week my colleagues and i
just turn on the computer
and are offering classes for middle high
school and college kids
about constitution 101 uh everything
from
the beginning through the bill of rights
it's so meaningful as you know saul
because you've been such a pioneer
to be able to use this covid crisis as
an opportunity
to offer free online education and
friends if you're
if you're watching at home i hope you'll
join us for these classes we just did
one today at noon
for constitution day a live class with
justice gorsuch
who's the honorary chair of the national
constitution center and we had
4 500 students of all ages middle school
uh up uh asking justice gorsuch
amazing questions so that's what the
constitution center does
in addition to all that um we're a
beautiful museum of the constitution
on independence mall in philadelphia uh
we're now open again so if you happen to
be in philadelphia come see the very
earliest drafts of the constitution
as well as the reconstruction amendments
the 19th amendment which gave women the
right to vote
and be inspired by the thrill of
learning
about the us constitution and this might
be uh
an obvious question but i think it's
worth asking
so the constitution actually this wasn't
obvious to me when i first learned it
you know you just learned the word
constitution and
like literally i was in my 30s one day
when i woke up in the morning i was like
oh because it constitutes the country it
like says what the country is made of
how does it run et cetera et cetera i
never made that connection like my
entire
life until i was like 38 years old but
why does it why is it important
obviously it's important to have a
constitution
but why is it important to keep
reflecting on it and studying it
you know to have students be able to
talk to supreme court justices to have a
museum around this why is that important
to keep reflecting on the constitution
you know you're so right to emphasize
that word constitute
because a constitution is what
constitutes us
as a people as we the people
and those words of the preamble we the
people of the united states
were hugely significant of the framer
james wilson
insisted that the preamble begin with we
the people of the united states not
his original draft we the people of the
states of rhode island
and virginia and so forth because we
believe that we the national people have
the sovereign power
it wasn't like england where the king
had the power
uh or uh where uh parliament had the
powers we the people
as a whole who have the power and we all
know
friends that these are such divided
times according to some
scholars who are more polarized at any
time since the civil war
the text of the constitution is the one
thing that continues to
bind and constitute us and doesn't mean
that we agree about
what it means always but we can agree
and disagree respectfully
on the basis of our constitutional not
our political views
and in that sense studying the
constitution and the various arguments
on all sides of constitutional questions
helps us to have the civil dialogue that
the framers thought was necessary
if we are continued to be constituted as
we the people
and even what you just pointed out about
how you know early revisions had
we the people of the states of versus
obviously the constitution we have which
is we the people of the united states
you know we take even words like united
for granted that's just the name of our
country united states
but that was a really important point
because you could have constituted as
essentially a
confederation of of of of
quasi-independent states or nations or
however you want to talk about it uh but
and that's obviously what the articles
of confederation were all about
uh but then they said well that's too
that's too federated
we're gonna be one one people that's
exactly right
and as you say that's all it was the
defect of the articles of confederation
that led
those guys to come to philadelphia in
1787 the articles of confederation
viewed each state as sovereign and in
order to do anything you had to have
unanimous consent
so it was impossible to pay off the war
debts to
uh have foreign policy individual states
for raising tariffs against each other
so the framers come to philadelphia with
this very difficult task they have to
create a central government strong
enough to protect common purposes
but constrained enough to protect
liberty and
uh it could have gone lots of ways the
very
it's so cool if you go on the
interactive constitution you can see the
early drafts of the preamble
and the very first words that wilson
chose weren't we the people was just
resolved the government of the united
states shall consist of a legislative
judicial and executive branch
that was it those three branches of
government were the big idea
but but note then after further debate
it was clear
those branches don't have the sovereign
power none of them can speak for us
we the people are sovereign but then the
that next profound question
which people are sovereign is it the
people of the individual states or the
sovereign states
now in insisting that the united states
were sovereign
and that the style of the united states
according to the second draft
shall be the united states of america
wilson was introducing a radical idea
james wilson or rather abraham lincoln
when the south tried to secede from the
union during the civil war
invoke james wilson's idea of national
popular sovereignty and said you can't
do that
southern states we the people of the
united states as a whole having made the
union
we need the consent of the entire people
to change it
and it took the civil war to settle that
question so
look at how much we've reflected on and
we haven't even gotten past the first
three words of the constitution
just by digging into the text the
history the
the the case law we can learn so much
about the evolving
notion of who we are as a people
that's very powerful and actually
another thing which you which you
touched on but you know these are these
things that i
i had like these epiphanies in my 30s
and i was like oh of course you know in
the united states we call each state a
state
because they were initially envisioned
to be like a state
like a a quasi-independent state in most
countries you call these provinces
you don't call them states uh but we've
we've kept that even though we really
are part of
of one one country um
quick question really kind of a
technical question uh which i think i
know the answer but let you answer it
from youtube smart bears say as asking
jeff
what are the prices to enter the classes
i'm assuming the ones with the supreme
court justices
can you attend the classes worldwide
what do the classes talk about
so glad you asked and thrilled to share
that they're
completely free you can sign up
uh on zoom and that'll allow you to chat
questions just as you're doing now but
we also stream them
on youtube and all the archive videos
are available
on our youtube site and on the
interactive constitution which you can
find at
constitutioncenter.org one of the
classes talk about we have a complete
schedule
from the fall through the spring week by
week
um and you can find those our remote
learning resource page
and they just this week we taught about
the constitutional convention
and my colleague curry sotner wheeled
her zoom camera
around signers hall and we went up to
individual statues of particular framers
and talked about
their ideas and how they influenced the
convention uh we're going to be
talking about the electoral college
about separation of powers we'll do deep
dives into each of the major amendments
the
all four clauses of the first amendment
the second amendment the fourth
amendment protecting unreasonable
searches and seizures
we'll talk about reconstruction and uh
slavery in the constitution
um it's just uh such a thrill
we just have this kind of crazy idea
that
everyone from middle school to high
school all the way up
is engaged enough to learn the kind of
substantive constitutional law
that justice gorsuch and the supreme
court interprets every day and it's
really exciting to see
everyone from middle school students and
we do different middle school and high
school classes
jumping right in reading the supreme
court opinions debating the ideas it's
very inspiring to see how
citizens are able to rise to the
challenge so i would love it if everyone
who's here would just check out the
schedule
watch them live watch the archive videos
on youtube tell me what you think
j rosen at constitutioncenter.org and uh
and learn about the constitution
together it's such a great privilege we
have
no i'm excited about frankly i want to
learn more but also to uh for my family
to engage with that i think that's
incredible
you know going into the constitution
itself and obviously people could
i actually highly recommend people to
look at the text of the constitution i
think
most people watching are fully capable
of reading it you don't have to be a
lawyer you don't have to be historian it
is quite
approachable but you know one of the
things that all has always fascinated me
is this notion of amendments
uh you know and we have the bill of
rights for first ten amendments
how the original authors of the
constitution
how much did they think it was going to
be an evolving document i i mean i guess
they they started off kind of out the
gate
evolving it a little bit with with the
bill of rights so so
and do you think they would have been
surprised that we haven't amended it
more they would have been surprised by
how much we have amended it
such a great question i mean we can tell
something about that
from the debate over whether to have a
bill of rights in the first place
so james madison who's the main author
of the constitution originally opposes a
bill of rights
because he thinks it's unnecessary or
dangerous it's unnecessary he says that
the constitution
itself is a bill of rights since it only
grants congress limited powers
therefore congress can't claim has the
power to abridge free speech for example
because it's not granted that power and
then he says it's dangerous to have a
bill of rights because
if you have a list of rights people
might wrongly think that if a right
isn't written down it's not protected
and he thought channeling the
declaration of independence that our
rights come from god or nature not from
government
and therefore you can't make a closed
list there's so many of them you
couldn't even begin to write them all
down
but then the anti-federalists persuaded
him to change his mind they basically
said better safe than sorry all the
state constitutions have bills of rights
since everyone knows what the rights are
let's write down the main ones which
they did
adding the ninth amendment which said
the enumeration of certain rights shall
not be construed to deny or disparage
others retained by the people that's a
reminder that don't assume if it's not
written down it's
not protected you know as to the
question of did they expect it to change
more would they be surprised
there have been only 27 amendments there
was definitely a variation of views on
this
jefferson who was not at the
constitutional convention he was in
paris at the time
thought there should be essentially a
new convention every generation and you
had to
allow each generation to go back to
first principles and draft a new
constitution and it would be great to
have
lots of amendments or even to start from
scratch madison completely disagreed
he was at the convention he thought it
was basically a miracle that this group
of fallible human beings were able to
come to the agreement that they did
and it would be really dangerous to roll
dice and open things up to another
convention
so he was much more uh reluctant to have
more amendments and he wanted us always
to be guided by what he called reason
rather than passion he wanted a very
slow and deliberative process for
constitutional change
and perhaps he he would not be
dissatisfied there have been relatively
few amendments
so that was some of the debate but uh
it's remarkable isn't it that there have
been only
27 amendments in all of american history
those first 10
by the bill of rights and each of them
is worth
studying one final thing i'll say is um
this evening at 6 30 p.m
live free on constitutioncenter.org we
are
giving our uh liberty medal the 2020
liberty medal to justice ruth bader
ginsburg
and it's an incredibly inspiring series
of video tributes from her favorite
opera singers and special friends uh
talking about uh all that she's done for
the constitution
and she has a very memorable vision
she says the constitution has become
ever more embracive
and when i asked her once what she meant
by that word she's meant
embracing the left out people not just
grudgingly
but with open arms so in justice
ginsburg's vision
the constitution was intended by its
framers to be
increasingly embracing so the promise of
the declaration of independence that all
men are created equal could be extended
to all men and women to people of
all races creeds colors to immigrants to
lgbtq people
she she believes that that more abrasive
constitution
was envisioned by the framers now others
disagree uh
uh people who are consider themselves
constitutional originalists
believe that the constitution is only
supposed to evolve
through the amendment process and any
efforts to
expand its protections through judicial
interpretation
are a violation of the original
understanding of the constitution
so that debate broadly between call them
originalists
or strict constructionists and living
constitutionalists
is very much alive on the supreme court
today and it's great just to study the
different methodologies of
constitutional interpretation
so you friends who are watching can make
up your own mind about
who you agree with are you a originalist
are you in a living constitutionalist
would you mix and match
different methodologies like pragmatism
or
representation reinforcement or
textualism we can kind of walk out by
thinking like a justice and talking
about those different approaches but
it's always really
inspiring to try to approach these
questions not in political
but in constitutional terms in other
words don't ask what you think the
government should do in a particular
case
but what you think the constitution
allows or forbids it to do
and be guided in your answer to that
question by being faithful to your
methodology so if you're a
originalist in one case you should be
that in another case even if it leads to
a result you don't like
and vice versa for a living constitution
so that's some of our
evangelism is to excite all of you
students who are watching
to think like a constitutional lawyer
learn those methodologies
and make up your own mind that was
fascinating
what would you say you know it does feel
like
earlier on in our history we had more
frequent amendments and
for very good reason we had some major
issues
uh in our in our early phases of our
country around slavery around women not
having the right to vote and obviously
even though the constitution got amended
the some of many of the inequities many
of the problems
have continued and to some degree some
of them are are still there
what do you think and and to some degree
maybe this more interpretive version
versus an originalist version of the
constitution
maybe makes the amendment process a
little bit less of a
must-have uh is one theory but i'm
curious
you know well i have a question from
actually from
india hussein hakeel says it's a lawyer
from india
enlighten us regarding the procedure of
amendment of the constitution of the u.s
and
the reason why i'd love you to answer
that question is because my perception
it's a very
hard thing to do and my second or third
part of this question
um is what do you think is in the
running four amendment i mean you know
we think we hear a lot of people talk
about the electoral college or
is you know every state getting a
senator only two senators california
has two senators while the next 40
million people have you know 40 senators
or whatever
uh what do you think is is is in the
running in maybe our lifetimes that
might where we might see an amendment
great question
a team from india india has such a
distinguished constitutional tradition
and your supreme court
is really one of the great and uh
really influential and important supreme
courts around the world
so how do you amend the us constitution
well there are a bunch of ways to do it
according to article five of the
constitution which sets out the
amendment process
first the amendment has to be proposed
there are two ways it can be proposed it
can either be proposed by
uh two-thirds of both houses of congress
or by a special constitutional
convention
called by congress on the application of
two-thirds of the states
most of the amendments that have been
proposed have used the first method
a proposal by congress we haven't had
another constitutional convention since
the first one and then it can be
ratified in two ways as well
it can be either ratified by three
quarters of the state legislatures
or by special conventions called in
three quarters
of the states so that's why the
constitution is so hard to
amend because you've got to jump through
all of those hoops and three-quarters is
a really high bar
what amendments are most likely the
one that's very much on the table is the
equal
rights amendment uh just last year
virginia
ratified the equal rights amendment um
after its proposal
in uh years after its proposal in uh
19 1980s or early 1980s
and some claim that because virginia
represents
basically the puts us over the
three-quarters hump
the ra should be part of the
constitution but others disagree
because the original era had a time
limit and said that it had to be
ratified by
the 1980s um and the time limit has
passed
and therefore in addition to the fact
that some states have rescinded their
ratification
people say it is not valid justice
ginsburg who is one of the most
influential advocates of the equal
rights amendment
thinks it would be safer to start from
scratch that there's enough doubt about
the validity of the ra
would be better to repose it and
re-ratify it because you want to be sure
that it's
definitely part of the constitution and
then in terms of what other amendments
are likely
surprisingly the amendment that has been
proposed most
often and ratified by most states is
i want to ask you to guess uh saul
because it wasn't intuitive to me but
it's the balanced budget amendment
which has gotten nearly two-thirds of
the states i think it's like
two three or four states short of the
three-quarters
um benchmark so if that's probably the
first one likely to be ratified if that
were actually to happen
then there's there's also been a term
limits amendment that's not nearly as
close to being ratified
and those two are at the uh are at the
top of the list
so just make sure i understand so the
balanced budget event actually was not
aware of this i mean
they should be like tracking this in the
news that would force a balanced budget
on the federal government
exactly right so that would be a huge
thing because then all of a sudden
fiscal policy as a tool
becomes significantly
stopped i guess especially for writing
deficits
imagine in the time of covid uh given
the deficits were running all of that
would be unconstitutional if we had a
balanced budget amendment so we have
huge
implications fascinating once the state
ratifies it can they undo their advocate
or they have to they have to vote again
to undo their ratification
they have to vote again and there's all
these really interesting legal questions
about whether you're allowed to or not
several states did undo or rescind their
ratifications of the era
and there's a debate among lawyers about
whether those radica those rescissions
are valid or not um in the end
it's it's sort of up to well the last
contested amendment we had was the 27th
amendment was originally proposed as the
original
second amendment back at the time of the
bill of rights and it says that congress
can't raise its salary without an
intervening election
it got a bunch of states that ratified
and then people forgot about it and then
in the 1990s i think
a a college student said hey
we're two states short of ratification
or so just a few more ratifications
since there's no time limit here
would make this part of the constitution
he got a failing grade
on the paper because his teacher thought
it was so outlandish but a bunch of
states took up the suggestion
ratified the amendment and the archivist
of the united states decided on his own
that it was part of the constitution
after the final ratification came
through
and certified it and it was then uh
inscribed in the constitution as the
27th amendment
and the story justice gorsuch told this
at noon today
he thinks that the guy had his grades
after the amendment was ratified but
it's a great example of how
when there's no time limit on an
amendment um it's kind of up to
well in that case just the archivist and
then people's willingness to accept it
about whether or not it's valid and the
question of decisions is equally
interesting that's incredible that's a
facet when did this happen what what
what well i think it became
uh i can pull out the interactive
constitution you guys will figure it out
but
it was in the early 1990s wow
and the and the equal rights amendment
you know i watched the i forgot the name
of the netflix i watched it with my wife
a couple of months ago about the the
attempt to pass the equal rights
amendment in the 70s uh and early 80s
which was and
and about the whole women's rights
movement and all of that that was all
intertwined with that
uh i highly recommend it i wouldn't
recommend it for like really young kids
it gets a little bit adult in some of
their things but um
what what would be the implications if
the equal rights amendment gets
fully adopted that's a really
interesting
question and here i'll just plug the
weekly podcast we do at the constitution
center called we the people where every
week i
call up a leading liberal and
conservative scholar and debate
questions like the one
so i'll just ask and we did have a
podcast on the era
and what it would mean a few months ago
and
as usual it's complicated people
disagree about what it would mean but
the
progressive scholar thought it would uh
be a strong basis for reproductive
rights
justice ginsburg has argued that
restrictions on a woman's right to
choose
violate not the right to privacy
of male doctors but the right of
equality of women whose life choices are
constrained
by uh not being able to choose to be
uh caregivers or not based on their own
individual choice
so it might be used to argue for
a right of reproduction and to argue to
strike down restrictions on that right
um others say that it would um
require for example uh lgbtq people to
have
transgender bathrooms and would forbid
uh
bathrooms that are marked for people who
identify as male
or female others disagree about
that um others say that it would uh
allow courts to root out unconscious
gender
bias um as a form of a violation of
discrimination on the basis of sex
rather than intentional discrimination
which so far the supreme court is held
as the only kind of
uh discrimination that's forbidden now
you can argue all of this
round or flat as the lawyers say and you
could say that since the constitution
already
guarantees equal protection of the law
and since the supreme court just last
term
in a 6-3 decision by justice gorsuch
held the title vii of the civil rights
act of 1964
in its forbidding discrimination on the
basis of sex covers not only gender
discrimination but also discrimination
on the basis of lgbtq status
that an era wouldn't add all that much
to that existing
statutory protection the final thing
i'll say and
when you ask a great constitutional
question there's always there's always a
technical answer that you can't know
unless you've heard the arguments on
both sides and i didn't notice until the
podcast justice ginsburg when she was an
advocate arguing before the supreme
court
said that discrimination on the basis of
sex should be treated just as
skeptically under the law as
discrimination on the basis of race
and the lawyer's test for that is called
strict scrutiny and it means that any
burdens on the right have to be
necessary to achieve a compelling
governmental interest
the supreme court never quite adopted
justice ginsburg standard and in the
virginia military institute case which
she wrote
which struck down separately equal
military academies for men and women
the court adopt said that um gender
discrimination should be treated nearly
as skeptically as discrimination on the
basis of race we needed an exceedingly
persuasive justification
an era would unequivocally guarantee
strict scrutiny and require a compelling
interest for gender discrimination
and in that sense it would certainly put
discrimination on the basis of sex
on the same legal plan as discrimination
on the basis of race
that's that's fascinating and i mean
it's also fun to see how
passionate you look like you know you're
like a an artist when you when you get
into this
you know just to get not make sure we're
not leaving everyone behind it i do have
two questions from youtube
smartbear is asking what is an amendment
and nish786 is what is meant by
amendments i feel so lost so
um that's another thing amendment
literally means to amend to add to
modify any
anything you would add to anything you
amend to my explanation of amendments
i just would add synonyms uh
change alter uh
put in add um i think i think that was
one of your words
change alter add um
is what an amendment is so the original
constitution
remember we said um didn't have a bill
of rights
so the first 10 changes to the
constitution are called amendments the
first amendment says
congress shall make no law abridging the
freedom of the speech of the press
and you had to amend or change the
constitution to guarantee that right of
free speech because it didn't appear
in the original constitution so an
amendment is a change to the
constitution but
it's actually quite a deep question of
course as all
of your great questions are because in
changing the constitution
you're incorporating a principle into it
that has just as much weight as the
original principles
so in some cases you have to read um the
original constitution
in light of its subsequent amendments
and to give the most important
example the original constitution only
bound
congress it didn't bound the states it
says congress shall make no law bridging
free speech it didn't say
the state shall make no law the 14th
amendment to the constitution
was intended to apply all of those
original amendments
um against the states as well as
congress through the privileges or
immunities calls
clauses called the doctrine of
incorporation and the bottom line
friends i know it's getting technical
again but it's usually important just
think of this
after the 14th amendment passed after
the civil war the states are just as
prohibited from
infringing free speech as congress was
before the 14th amendment they were free
to infringe free speech and federal
constitution so that's what an amendment
is and anytime you want to change the
constitution
uh at least changes text you have to
pass an amendment
yeah it's you're definitely adding to
the text of the constitution i guess you
could or to the
the overall text i guess you could say
because you're adding more uh and it
could be a change
to your point uh with the 14th amendment
or could be clarification you know the
the the first amendment doesn't
contradict the rest of the constitution
to madison's point
but it makes it very clear that uh you
have the right to free speech
jeff i mean time goes by super fast
whenever we have these interesting
conversations i'll just end you know
a few people were just asking a few
questions you know i've known you for
several years and
i always like geeking out with you about
anything but especially uh
history and and the constitution uh but
nirbhay salujah from youtube says jeff
what is an inspiration for your academic
aspect of life maybe i'll interpret that
like why did you get into this why
you know how did you get into being the
head of the national constitution center
what has driven kind of your clear
passion for this subject
well i've just always loved reading and
history and words
and i was an english major in college
and i had some sense then that my
mission in life was to bring together
english and government i didn't even
know what that meant but i just felt
uh impressed to try to pursue that
passion
and i found that in the study of the
constitution in law school i went to law
school and i just was
kindled with excitement about the
significance of studying the text
and trying to understand the arguments
on both sides and looking at the
philosophical foundations
and just growing and learning and
serving this much broader
goal friends which is that this document
unites all of us so my path was that i
began
after law school as a journalist i was
writing about the supreme court uh
full-time for a while and i loved doing
that
then i started teaching constitutional
law at gw law school where i still teach
and then out of the blue as many of the
greatest opportunities in life to
the chance to uh work at this amazing
institution the national constitution
center presented itself
and i i've been lucky enough to work
there since 2013 and i just feel lucky
every single day i go to work my amazing
colleagues
and i just have the opportunity to teach
and learn and grow along with
all of you and it's such a it's such a
privilege in
in these times to to have this task
this mission of convening people of
different perspectives to learn about
the constitution
constitution day is a great way to do it
it's wonderful to do what you sell
because you're just doing so much to
inspire
people around the world to learn about
the constitution and i want to thank
not only all of our incredible friends
who are here in the us but also those of
you who are
tuning in around the world to be
inspired by this great document
of human freedom which has meant so much
to unite
we the people across america and around
the globe
no that's that's that's so inspiring
actually one last question i know a
little bit over time but i can't i
really want to ask
just given you know all you hear about
in the media and the news is on both
sides you know
it's very polarized you know one party
will view the other party as
you know detached and crazy and then
likewise and symmetric
some people will even invoke that we you
know constitutional crises this is not
where do you think we are on that
journey do you think the that you know
what
all the tension we see in politics are
just part of our you know growth as a
nation and we're gonna get to a better
place or do you do
do you have worries well there's no
doubt that it's a very serious time for
america those
uh statistics which are by historians
that were more polarized than in any
time since the civil war
are very concerning um in 1960
there was a 50 overlap between the most
conservative democrat and most liberal
republican in congress
today there is no overlap and we all
know how
social media has amplified the
partisanship and the anger of our
political discourse
in a way that seems to empower the very
factions
which madison defined as any group
either a majority or a minority
animated by passion rather than reason
devoted to self-interest rather than the
common good
it seems like we're seeing a lot of that
rule by passionate faction by
by tweet and share rather than by the
reasoned deliberation of the framers
before on the other hand i have to say
that you know having this amazing job
that i do
i have the opportunity every day to see
how when you just take the time
to sit down and have a thoughtful
conversation with people of different
perspectives
and i encourage people to do exactly
what i'm encouraging all of you to do
now
which is to set aside your political
disagreements because we're not going to
persuade each other about politics
but to have enough humility to learn
deeply
about something you don't already know
the answer to namely what
does the text say what were the original
founding stories that gave rise to it
what is the supreme court said what are
the philosophical
arguments that undergird these
principles
and how should they apply in light of
changing technologies these are such
hard and rich questions that you end up
after spending some time thinking about
it
i always end up in a surprising place
having learned something that i didn't
know before
so i am very encouraged that as long as
we continue to create the spaces the
platforms like you're creating song like
we're trying to create
a constitution center where people can
just take the time to
have these civil dialogues i am
optimistic that
the us constitution will continue to
provide a framework for civil dialogue
and that we the people will continue to
rule ourselves
by reason no well that that too is very
inspiring and i got to say because i've
had the luxury of you know we've done
this in a few khan academy videos and
national constitution center videos
where we went into some of the supreme
court cases and you know a lot of these
cases i entered in like surely they
would vote this way
any reasonable person would but when you
actually go into the into the
the details the intricacies of the case
you're like oh i guess they do have a
good point and
oftentimes you switch you switch your
position when you really learn what's
going on so yeah i love that call to
just
double triple click on things don't just
take it you know just don't look at
things and
and get outraged as quickly as possible
you know try to try to
exercise some humility and understand
the other side so
jeff thank you so much happy uh
constitution day
and i think this was a real treat on on
constitution day
happy constitution data everyone so
excited to learn with you
and check out the interactive
constitution pick an amendment or a
pause that you didn't know about dig in
deep and enjoy the learning it's just
such a
joy to be able to learn and grow
together happy constitution day
all right thanks thanks chef
well uh thanks everyone for joining as
always really fun conversation
i highly recommend going to the national
constitution center's website
look at the interactive constitution
attend those classes you might see me as
one of your
classmates in some of those classes
because i think um not only will it help
you appreciate history and how law
and nations are constituted uh but it'll
it'll actually build your critical
thinking skills and i actually think the
more people
that dig into these issues at a higher
level of depth i actually think that can
help
the polarization problem because you can
still disagree with the other side
but you can start to understand some of
the reasoning
uh for why a reasonable person might
come to a conclusion that you don't
so with that uh thank you so much for
joining
let's see i think the next show is going
to be on tuesday
of next week so have a good weekend see
y'all
you